hello belief nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to go off and change the planet now
I started to believe love series because
being a relationship can be hard and
being an entrepreneur can be hard you
combine both of those two things
together life gets a lot more difficult
and I thought it'd be a great gift for
myself anemic by relationship as well as
you guys too every week explore new
topics new ways to kind of make your
relationship better so today we're going
to learn from Jordan bean Peterson on
how to train your heart you're having an
argument with your partner and you say
you're a stupid person and you've always
been a stupid person and as far as I can
tell it's far into the future as I can
see you're going to remain a stupid
person so what are they supposed to do
what are they going to do when you say
that they're going to cry like if you
mean it they're going to get angry if
you mean it and they don't like you very
much and why is that
well it's like it's a salt basically the
only way really the only thing that you
can do in a situation like that is walk
away ignore it respond in kind or MD
generates into violence that's it
because there's no discussion you
haven't left the person anywhere to go
you've gone right to the top of their
hierarchy and said everything about you
is wrong and worse than that all the
mechanisms that we could use to correct
it won't work so those are fighting
words so don't do that unless you want
to have a fight so then you might say
well what would you do instead and the
answer is deliver the least amount of
information you possibly can and so
let's say you come home and your person
is watching TV and you kind of hoping
they'd greet you at the door you can't
you shouldn't break down into tears and
say you're a stupid person you've always
been the stupid person meant you can't
be a stupid person in the future you
should say I have this peculiarities and
that is that when I come home I don't
have enough confidence to just be
copy I would like you to come and say
just shut the TV off for two minutes
come to the front door and say hello
then you can go back and watch your TV
would it be okay if you did that and
they'll think well you'll have to pay
for it somehow but then they'll they'll
probably do it and so but the thing is
is you got to specify the routine that
you want transformed at the highest
possible level of resolution and you
want to you want to recommend the
minimal necessary change that will
satisfy you it so you can't say if you
love me you'd know how to greet me at
the door
how not helpful because they're stupid
right and so are you so you have to
spell it out it's like what do you want
things exactly what would make you
satisfied and then you have to have your
person like grudgingly practice out a
few times and you have to let them do it
very badly and also in a bad temper and
then you have to reward them for it and
then maybe three months later they'll do
it properly so you need to know that
because that's what people are like it's
very hard for them to learn new things
and they're very resistant to it but
they're very responsive to reward it so
another thing this is partly what BF
Skinner figured out so when he was
training rods and he wanted rap to do
something one of the things he would do
is he put maybe he was going to train
the rap to climb up a little louder I
mean he could get rats to climb ladders
and then climb across like the little
bunch of bars and then spin around three
times and then you know whack a ball and
then eat something like he got
incredibly complex behavior out of
breath and the way he did that was
patience so he put the ladder in the
cage and the rat could just run around
doing rat things and then it would put
its hand on me on the first run and
Skinner would give it a pellet and so he
did you know after even once the rats
going to be like stand in the immediate
vicinity of the ladder and then the
frequency with which it's going to go
like this it's just increase so that it
doesn't again bang
tell it well soon the rat is just going
like this right so then you wait until
the rat tries the other hand so you give
it a pellet then well then it's going
like this and then because it's going to
get
or it'll go like this it'll hit the next
Eric bang you give it a pellet soon the
routes climbing and doing all the little
things you want it to do now the problem
with that is you have to be patient you
have to wait till the rat does what you
want okay that's more relationship
advice wait till that does what you want
and then reward it and it's unbelievably
useful it's also extraordinarily
positive I mean I'm being you know
Carmical it in so far as I can manage
that about the situation but people love
reward and they love attention
people love attention more than anything
else and so if you're what we watch
through the day and when your partner
does something that's good say man that
was good or something like that you can
be inventive and then you'll do it more
and if you do that a whole bunch like
for a year they'll be doing things that
are good for you just all the time but
you have to be patient which is very
annoying and you have to suppress your
response to only respond to negative
things you know because what we know
about the expectancy models is that a
deviation from expectation produces a
burst of negative emotions you know so
you come home and the whole house is
clean
but there's like I don't know the dog
has shed on the rug or something and the
person overlooked taps like you're not
going to see the clean house you're
going to see that rug with the dog fur
on you're going to say why didn't you
clean up the rug with the dog fur and
they're going to say good luck getting
me to clean up the house again and you
know because the thing is is the
exception stands out and what's done
doesn't and the reason for that is you
can just ignore what stuff because it's
done it doesn't get in your way so it
gets invisible really quickly so you
really got to watch that tendency one of
the things Nietzsche said was that if
you really want to punish someone you
don't punish them when they do something
wrong to expect that that's not a
punishment they expect that they might
even be relieved by it you want to
punish them when they do something right
because then you'll really hurt them and
so that's something to think about in
your if you're in a relationship now if
someone's done something right
do not punish them you do that two or
three times and that's it and you're not
going to get them to do that anymore so
judicious Ness watch what they're doing
if something happens that good that's
good notice it and you know if they've
done a bunch of things don't concentrate
on the things they did wrong that's not
smart it's really hard on them to like
it is in some sense this sounds
manipulative and selfish you know
because I'm teaching you how to train
your partner but yeah but you should
also teach them how to train you because
it would be really nice if you could
come home and the person would say well
what did you do today and you say you
know here's a bunch of things I did and
they said use they say well this looks
really good and that was great why are
you do some more that you're like oh boy
it was a great day and so you know you
can train them to train you properly and
that's a really helpful thing especially
if you do it over a few years you know
you can that's how you have a good
relationship because you're both
clueless as hell to beginning it you
don't know even what would make you
happy much less what would make the
other person happy and so you got to
figure these things out bit by bit and
then you have to inform each other and
then you have to be patient enough to
let your partner do these things really
badly I'll give you another example
sometimes sometimes I I see couples
sporadically in my in my clinical
practice I'm not a couple's counselor
and so but sometimes when I'm working
with someone there's an issue that needs
to be discussed with with both people
because otherwise it's just stupid and
one of the things I often recommend to
people especially what they have kids is
that they set aside to use an
anachronistic phrase date date nights
well everyone hates that idea it's like
they say well you know they'll just say
that's I'm not doing that that would be
one objection we're just not doing that
you know that's what we did before we
got married they'll say well my partner
would never go for that they got a bunch
of excuses why that isn't going to work
and so I've heard all those excuses I
know all of them and then maybe I
convinced them yeah yeah
sure I know this is stupid it's awkward
it's it's it's artificial that's okay
just try it once so then they go and try
it and then they come back and they say
we had an absolutely miserable time
really we had a miserable time we
couldn't agree on what movie to go to
and then you know she took me to her
movie and I really didn't like it so we
fought all the way home we're never
doing that again and I say well really
you've got 30 years 400 days that's
12,000 days okay so you're not going to
do that you're going to spend the next
12,000 days without having any real
romantic evenings and interactions with
your spouse that's your plan I like
doing I like doing arithmetic with my
client say they hate that I hate
arithmetic it's like well no that sounds
like a bad idea said okay well would you
like some romance in your life are you
just done with that well really like you
know people can go for a long time with
no romance at all say well no maybe we'd
like some of that
well how much once a year well know once
a month well know once every two weeks
well sometimes people are really busy
it's like okay that beats the hell out
of zero once a week twice a week okay
whatever we're going to we're going to
start with a range okay what would a
good evening look like like if you could
both get exactly what you wanted what
would it look like well they have to
think about that because the the
previous theory was my stupid partner
should know what I liked and that's what
their partner is thinking too it's like
good luck with that because know they
don't have a clue especially if they're
men they don't have a clue that says you
have to tell them what you want and how
they could deliver it and vice versa
which is very awkward and horrible and
then you have to practice it for six
months because you know it takes a lot
of practice to do something
sophisticated really well and then if
you do that it's like poof you got it
for the rest of your life so it's worth
the aggravation you know when the first
time the rat puts its paw up on the
ladder it's just sort of doing it
accidentally you can't expect it to do
it well and that's exactly how to view
your own progress and the progress of
your partner's like let them do it badly
for a while
least they're doing it so and if you
think they should do it faster well look
real hard and see how easy it is to
change your own behavior because it's
really hard to change your own behavior
everybody says I'm going to exercise
three times a week
new years it's like no one does they buy
the memberships and then they feel
guilty for having them but they don't
actually go to the gym and that's a
perfect example of how difficult it is
to transform behavior thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know what
did you think what did you take to this
video that you are going to apply
somehow to your relationships she would
continue this series or not it's still a
new one for us and it's kind of on the
football
I'd like it to but you guys ultimate
into the side let me know leave it down
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you
because you need to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
see you soon